all right doctors
how about a fashion show
[Music]
so i mentioned uh recently that i was
going to be doing a number of revisits
to various doctor who lists that i've
done over the years uh however there is
one list that i need to do fresh for the
first time and that is
i gotta talk about the different outfits
that the doctor has worn and give my
assessment of what i think are the best
i had to think for a while about how i
wanted to present this because
initially
i thought i would just you know take the
iconic look of each of the uh doctors
that we've had so far and just rank
those but the problem is like there were
enough
alterations and shifts and changes to
the outfits of most of the doctors over
the course of their time in the part
that
whatever outfit i picked there would
have been somebody in the comments like
well this would have ranked higher if
you'd g if you'd use this version of
their outfit instead of the one you did
so that didn't make sense to do i never
considered the possibility of ranking
literally every single outfit of every
doctor because i don't even know how
many that is but it's a lot and some of
them are different by tiny miniscule
amounts and i am not up for parsing that
i don't know maybe in the future
somebody can pay me to do that but right
now no so what i'm doing instead is i'm
giving my top 10. now
as i should always point out when i do a
top 10 which is not a comprehensive i'm
not taking
it's not like there's only 10 outfits
that i'm ranking them i need to point
out just because it's not in this list
doesn't mean it's not good there are
actually many good outfits that i like
on the doctor that aren't on this list
honestly there's almost no outfit that i
don't like at least a little there's
some that i like less than others
obviously i managed to do a rank but
i don't really go
completely to almost any of them i'm not
going to say none of them that
i've tried to get on board with six's
rainbow coat i just i can't
i just can't
but anyways here are my picks for the
top 10 best outfits
that the doctor has worn
going through the entire history all
things are possible
let's see what we got
number 10
the eighth doctor specifically in the
night of the doctor
now the thing about the eighth doctor is
i've always liked palm again in this
part even in the tv movie which isn't
very good he's great in it but his
outfit felt
well it it felt like what it was it felt
like
an american's interpretation of oh he's
he's british and he's kind of man out of
time put him in this victorian
looking thing that's that'll work right
i'm like i mean
yeah but it's kind of generic but seeing
bits and pieces of that outfit things
reminiscent of that original outfit from
the tv movie
now beaten up
worn down
and getting the impression that he just
has been too busy
to change or clean his outfit in a long
time it felt like it spoke a lot about
where the doctor was at the point we see
him in that short
and i liked it both as a look
and as a storytelling detail
i dig that
number nine
the seventh doctor's outfit and
specifically for photo reference you're
seeing as he appeared in remembrance of
the daleks now at a couple of times he
had a different colored coat he had a
brown one for a little bit i like this
one best i feel like the white does a
better job of kind of obfuscating what
is going on because here's what i like
about the seventh doctor or actually let
me back up the second doctor as much as
i love uh patrick trouten he was never
really in consideration because his
outfit you just look at it and you're
immediately like oh
what's going on with you now that works
it matches his characterization
beautifully but it's not an appealing
thing to look at what i like about the
seventh doctor's outfit is
at first glance or had a distance you
could look at it and go oh yeah okay
that's fine but the more you look at it
and the closer you get to it you're like
wait a minute those pants don't really
go with what's going on what's with all
the question marks i i like that it r it
reads almost normal from a distance but
then gets weird when you get up close to
it i like that contrast and in a way
that also very much fits
the seventh doctor the view that a lot
of the people who tried to take him on
or tried to stop him had of him when
they first ran into him was very
different from when they got to know him
and i mean that's often true of the
doctor but with the seventh it was it
was a kind of a core part of how he
functioned and i like how that's
reflected in this specific outfit and i
think it's the best one he had and it
works for me
number eight
the 12th doctor's outfit
in the pilot so this is the kickoff for
series for series 10. now okay trying to
select an outfit for the 12th doctor is
a nightmare because i swear
nearly every single episode
it's a slightly different outfit like he
would use the same coat for big
stretches but like the shirt underneath
it would change from episode to episode
or he did have a couple of other
different coats that he went through but
like it wasn't massively changed but
there were like little tiny tweaks and
almost never the same thing but i love
this one can i be honest
mainly because of the hoodie
i love the contrast of
the the waistcoat you know buttoned up
still having that little bit of essence
of him being more uptight as he was back
when he started in the roll back in
series eight but with the casualness
kind of draped over that or seeping
through it almost
i love that blend and it feels again
incredibly on point for where the doctor
is as a person because
i've talked about the 12th doctor's arc
and his journey as a whole going from
more tightly wound to
relaxing and getting possibly a little
too comfortable in series nine and then
in series 10 finding the balance and i
think visually that balance is here as
well he's still got you know a little
bit of that up tightness but there's
just a more relaxed vibe
mixed with it and that's here visually
and that really works
number seven
the tenth doctor in the pinstripe suit
with the coat i do think it needs the
coat i'm not that the pinstripe suit is
bad it does work but the the thing is
sometimes the dog sometimes the coat
really feels like it completes an outfit
sometimes a coat well we could take it
or leave it works with or without
i i think here it really does add a
little something to it i think partially
because of the little tweaks that it
does along with a few other tiny details
that actually boost this up a lot higher
than it might have been otherwise
because just the pinstripe suit on its
own it's cool it's nice i like it but
there's little things that are a little
off that you wouldn't expect from
somebody with such a well-tailored suit
he doesn't have the tie
tight the top button of his shirt isn't
buttoned it's like he got out of work
and was like uh
get a little more casual the shoes that
he's wearing do not match at all and
honestly the coat
always has looked a little big on him
not
badly not like oh that doesn't fit him
at all but just like
that's that's like a little too big
and it's that slight off-ness which
keeps it from being too classically like
oh handsome man was like well no there's
little things that are off which again
the doctor should be at least slightly
off in their appearance however it may
be and these little touches contrasted
against the tightness of the suit i mean
the tightness in terms of how uniform
the look is and also the literal
tightness of the suit all the elements
just complement each other really really
well
number six
the third doctor
very specifically in the day of the
daleks now i gotta be super specific on
this because there were a number of very
again appropriate to this version of the
doctor very flamboyant there were a lot
of sort of velvet coats kind of things
but this look
the red coat with the purple because the
red coat on its own isn't bad but it
doesn't quite do it with for me you
bring the purple in on that
and it clicks way way better for me and
i'm not a fashion commentator i can't
exactly explain why it does
but it's like the missing piece that i'm
hoping for
with most of his other looks the only
other thing that came close was like his
his uh first season on
in the role you know he had kind of the
more
almost magician-esque look but it that
wasn't quite clicking for me and there's
something about the way it's slightly
shifted into this look
this just clicks for me i just love
looking at it
number five
the 13th doctor specifically with the
red shirt now i actually like
both versions of this doctor's primary
outfit and while i personally have a
cosplay in the navy blue shirt with the
rainbows on it i think the red works a
little bit better because it breaks up
the colors because otherwise with the
other one you've got the inner lining of
her coat is a dark blue the shirt i mean
there's the rainbow on it but the
t-shirt is also kind of a dark blue the
pants they're a lighter blue but it's a
lot of blue getting the red in there too
i feel breaks it up in a way that is
just more visually appealing and i i
cannot ignore
the uh the thing with the fact that her
pants are first of all in suspenders
that are a color that like why would you
even have that color suspenders and that
the pants don't even get down to the
boots and the boots are these heavy duty
things
it it does reflect again what actually
happened going to uh a consignment shop
or a charity shop or whatever it was and
just grabbing what fit and
i like this look
i'm possibly slightly biased in his
favor because i cosplayed well not with
the red shirt but i basically cosplay
this look and maybe that's maybe more
favorable to it i don't know but
i do like it and i think this is the
best version of it
number four
the 11th doctor
in the second half of series seven
this was kind of funny to me when i
looked at all of his outfits and
realized i liked this one best
because this is the stretch of the
seventh doctor
run of matt smith's run that i like the
least overall
but it's a dang good look i like the
purple and there's just a little bit
more of a flare to it while i like his
his series 5 look it does look a bit
like well some aging professor out of
college and while the contrast of that
with how young matt smith was when he
first got the part did absolutely work
just as a look completely taken in a
vacuum it's like it's it's a bit dull
but
the extra flare of the colors of the
purple of the coat being longer than
just that jacket he started out with
it's just these little tweaks while
staying absolutely true to the core
essentials of the 11th doctor's look
because bowties are cool
i really really like this one
number
three
the fugitive doctor
so yes i did put into consideration
the war doctor and the fugitive doctor
the war doctor
ultimately like it functioned for the
story but i didn't really love that look
this look
i like a lot
and again a lot of it has to do with
contrast i love how many buttons they
are i love how bold the buttons are how
much they stand out that they are these
metallic buttons as opposed to being a
color that is meant to blend in with the
uh with the waist coat and with the
jacket i love that pop but more than
anything i love that
top half is very dark blue you know it's
a navy blue then we've got black on the
bottom and with the shoes
but then these
shots of color
up here and in the uh and in the cuffs
and i love that the cuffs
while they are colors that match and fit
with each other they're not the same
slightly different colors on each cuff
and i think the way that those pops of
color again sort of contrast with and
break up the much more put together
overall look i think works really well
it's a very commanding look which for
the way joe martin played the part again
suits the character really really well i
think this is just a phenomenal
look
i really hope we get to see more of it
number two
the 12th doctor again so yeah this is
the one doctor who does appear on here
more than once um because that was a
possibility but the thing was when i
looked at all the other doctors whose
appearances i do like and their
variations oftentimes the variations to
like say some of the stuff that's
already on this list they were either
you know i either thought they were
inferior and i picked the best variation
and the other ones were far enough away
they weren't also adding to the list or
the tweaks were so minor it's like well
that's
basically what i am picking so there's
no point putting that on here even
though if i were to rank every outfit
they would be close together i so i
didn't want to do that but
the 12th doctor
in
i just i just keep finding new ways to
praise this
world enough in time and the doctor
falls
now here's what's funny about this
this look is actually far more
reminiscent of how he looked when he
first started back in series eight that
more tight and controlled and buttoned
up uh restrained look that i mentioned i
liked his his addition of the hoodie of
things loosening up
this look here is actually a lot closer
to that more tight look but there's one
detail about it that honestly
this sounds like it should be a minor
thing
but it makes
all the difference
it's the cuffs
it's that the cuffs are pulled out from
the ends of his sleeve the most that
they have been
in all the different outfits he's had
and
they're unbuttoned we've seen visible
cuffs on the doctor before even you know
back to when he started in series eight
as i mentioned but they haven't come out
this much and they were buttoned or they
had cufflinks
here they're loose they're open
and
there's a bit of a flare to that and
there's a bit of a uncontrolled feeling
to that especially the way that capaldi
physically acts in this part in the way
that not only those cuffs but he has
bandage on one of his hands the way that
this is used to emphasize things
visually from pulling attention to his
hand being against that tree when he's
holding back regeneration to the way it
draws immediate attention when he is
pointing at the master and missy during
that speech that i love so much
this tiny touch
of the cuffs being pulled further out
and being open
changes so much about how the outfit
feels and it makes it work in a way it
didn't when those were when those were
tight and buttoned up
and yes
possibly bumping this up uh more than it
deserves because
it's
my favorite story of my favorite doctor
in my favorite series of modern arab
doctor who so like i'm not going to
pretend that there isn't some kind of
bias here but i really did think i would
put this below the hoodie look but i
looked at them side by side and i'm like
i actually like this more i had to
really think about why
and it does largely come down to this
one tiny thing that shouldn't make so
much of a difference but it really did
it really did for me and i did debate
doing this version or the more torn up
version that we see him have in twice
upon a time which does work quite well
uh as well but
i like this one a little bit better than
when it's all beaten up in that one
so
yeah
you should have known i was gonna find a
way to put the 12 doctor on here twice
okay not to mention the fact that like
the sheer number of outfits on that man
there was always a good chance this was
gonna happen
number
one
like
it feels cliche
what i'm about to do here it feels trite
it feels obvious but you know what i
don't care
fourth doctor
his look in his first season
absolutely
perfect
again
these aspects that
don't feel completely off except for the
scarf which we'll get to but you know
the coat the hat that's like a little
too floppy doesn't feel like it properly
contains his hair like maybe with the
hair like that he shouldn't even be
wearing a hat but he does
and it fits his personality wonderfully
but then the addition of the scarf the
scarf that is impossible to miss it's
impossible to ignore no matter what else
you think of everything else he's
wearing
that scarf
grabs attention and that scarf is iconic
for good
reason
the length of it the flow of it the
pattern on it it's perfect
and they did alterations to this look he
had slightly different similarly long
scarfs for later seasons i still like
this one the best
when i think
what does the doctor look like
even though
my favorite doctor is a different one i
am way more familiar with the modern
eras than the classic
this is still the image that comes to my
head first
given that i can't put it anywhere other
than first
absolutely stellar iconic look that you
would not mistake for anything else from
any other show
ever
and i think it's the best
what about you
what are your favorite outfits that the
doctor has worn or what do you think
about my ranking if you want to tell me
how wrong i am either way that works too
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon is how i am
able to do this and keep the entire
operation up and running any amount of
support is incredibly helpful
um but you know there's other things if
you want to support me as well like
share subscribe there's links to other
things in the description such as twitch
i have a coffee now um you know
instagram tick tock all those things
um i appreciate any and all of it but
you also don't have to
because my friends no matter how you
chose to get dressed up today
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
patreon shout outs thank you to turok
shane ross oliver b melinda walters
robin powell for nobulax the poodle
edelen tracy scrabbit dharma michael
doyle vincent paul bartolucci angry
casper adam lefty taylor robin moore
shayla gourley and bookworm
you can support me as well
hear me mispronounce your name
sure i got some of those wrong
[Music]
bye
[Music]